I'm in fact Cooper thanks come on the
show today
um net migration figures have come out
today they would have shot people I want
to come to Labor's Solutions such as
they are in a bit but first I want to
ask you about fundamental points about
your attitude to immigration how it's
evolved you supported remain in the
referendum for clarity you were in favor
of unlimited EU migration into the UK
under freedom of movement that was your
position in the past
so as you know labor did way back at the
referendums Port remained but brexit is
in place now and we are clear we need to
make brexit work on immigration our
policy is to have a points-based system
and to reform that points-based system
not to go back to free movement actually
we need to focus on the points-based
system and how we make it work for the
UK it's not working at the moment
particularly because it is not linked to
skill shortages in the economy and some
of the long-term problems in our country
and I want to get on to Labor's policy
but the reason I asked you about that to
start off with is that labor leader
kirstarma four years after the brexit
vote stood before Labor party members
and said under the head in my pledges to
you this on migration he said defend
migrants rights full voting rights for
EU Nationals defend free movement as we
leave the EU how much of that set of
policies are still operational so we've
left the EU and Kia has said very many
times our policy as a point space system
we're not returning to free movement so
there are changes we're not returning to
free movement definitely not there are
changes we want to make to the
points-based system particularly linked
to skills yeah but the we're very clear
it's a points-based system is the right
advantage and does he want to see EU
Nationals voted in UK general elections
that's not policy I know there are
debates about all all sorts of these
issues but it's not policy he said it
back in uh 2020 he said it full voting
rights for EU Nationals and he's also
said since this is not our policy okay
so that isn't labor policy anymore
that's right it seems that the low
policy have gone undergone a collective
conversion about this from freedom of
movement to now a points-based system it
has evolved clearly and I want to come
to those Solutions you talk about but
just to start off is 606
000 net migration figure is it too high
why I think the net migration should
come down from these unusually high
levels I think that we would expect it
to come down because obviously it
includes the Ukraine and Hong Kong
figures which I think everybody would
agree we support the action to help
people from Ukraine and Hong Kong but
the other concern for us in these
figures is there's been a doubling of
the number of work visas in just a few
years they've gone up by a hundred and
twenty percent and we still have skills
shortages across the country so that I
think is the real failing and that's why
our policies would actually address some
of these skills you don't have this
continual switch towards overseas
recruitment rather than training
migration good or bad for the UK economy
we're always going to need International
Recruitment and let's be clear that our
country has benefited for Generations
from people who've come here to build
our biggest businesses to work in our
public services and be part of our
country that's who we are but this
system also needs to be properly
controlled and managed so that it's fair
and there is this problem at the heart
of it which is these growing skills
shortages that are never never being
addressed and that's why we want those
skill shortages addressed of course in
something like Health and Social care
we're going to continue to need a health
and social care Visa but it's a serious
problem that we're just not training
enough nurses and doctors here in the UK
your big sort of policy is around skill
shortages you're not going to give an
overall Target for net migration figures
but will you promise the British people
that there will be fewer work visas
granted by labor than the current
government there were three hundred
thousand in the year to March 2023 so
can I take it that given this is the
centerpiece of your policy you will at
least pledge that to the British people
that you will bring the number of work
visas down over a labor government well
we're not set in targets but what we are
doing is setting practical policies and
I think that's the right way to do it
because to be honest I think for too
long people have seen ever since 2010
people have seen politicians sit there
and set targets and make all these
promises and they've all actually been
meaningless so what we're instead doing
is setting out what the policies would
be and the policies would be to say when
you've got occupations on the shortage
occupation list which accounts for
around half of all skilled worker visas
those jobs should be linked to proper
training plans in the UK Engineers have
been on the shortage list for about 15
years no proper plan to make sure you
get the training in the UK so you've got
50 000 shortfall every year According to
some estimates so you link it first of
all with the training plans particularly
that means around the NHS where we would
have a substantial increase which would
mean the NHS wouldn't need the same
scale of recruitment from overseas and
then also I don't know if you want to
come on to this getting rid of this pay
discount in the immigration system which
is also really unfair and is an
incentive for employers to recruit from
overseas rather than labor have made a
train in the years you've made it clear
that you want to tackle skill shortages
with domestic workers but what I'm
hearing too is that labor are having a
go at the government about net migration
figures and at the same time you won't
set your own targets about where you
want the level to go to neither will you
commit to Bringing Down the level of
work visas now so I think that's having
your cake and eat it you have a go at
them but you won't set your own targets
that is what is clear to me well what
we're criticizing them for is having no
plan and having no grip and that
ultimately is the difference both on
immigration and us on Asylum we're
setting everything but the public judge
you if you say we will have this plan
but you won't give them anything to
measure you about which is for example
not unreasonable if you're going to
train all these workers to say by the
end of the next Labor Parliament elects
Naval government over five years we will
bring work visas down from the current
levels that seems to me a very modest
ambition if you deliver on these pledges
I think the more important thing to be
honest is to set out the Practical plan
and I can go through another part of our
plan which would be a substantial reform
we would get rid of the current 20
discount in the immigration system which
means that employers where they've got
shortage occupation which is a lot of
occupations they can recruit people at
20 percent less than the going rate the
going rate's already lower than the
average rate so that is a really big
discount on average pay that allows
employers to recruit at level that level
from overseas now that is an incentive
for those employers to recruit from
overseas rather than to train at home
rather than to pay fairly at home and to
be honest I just think everybody I
should be paid the going rate Kirsten
has talked about when he sees a vision
for Britain he hasn't talked about A
Five-Year Plan he has talked about a
decade plan he has talked if you like in
blue thinking terms or Blue Sky Thinking
about a 10-year program for government I
mean annalize Dodds your predecessor and
Labor's chair has been honest about
about it she told Sky News potential in
some areas where there's a short-term
need for skills you could see in the
short term actually people who are
coming in increasing in numbers that
that's true isn't it it could actually
go up before it comes down fair I think
that um the net migration figures I
believe in that migration figures should
come down and also actually I would
expect them to come down because you've
got Ukraine figures and uh the other
figures around Hong Kong as well but we
also think on the issues around the work
visas we really should be investing in
the UK and we really should be investing
in training as well don't get me wrong
there will always be important
International Recruitment and that will
continue to be the case we're going to
need talent and skills you know the best
talent and skills from all over the
world and my right into thinking that
you did not like the storm attack ads
claiming the Prime Minister does not
believe adults convicted of sexually
assaulting children are going to go to
prison
like that did you I'm not going to
apologize for hard-hitting ads that
recognize that the Prime Minister has
been in charge and is part of a
conservative country a conservative
government that has been in charge for
13 years there have been a whole series
of failures around the criminal justice
system and one of the biggest failures
has been the huge drop in the charge
rate that's across all kinds of crimes
you know we've dropped from around about
two-thirds in terms of the charge rate
that does bluntly mean more criminals
are getting off and more victims are
being let down the reason I asked partly
vote if you don't mind is that the
Fallout of that rare was taught that
you'd slightly fallen out with starmer
that he might not you might not
continuous had Shadow Home Secretary is
that all rubbish do you expect it yeah
yes do you expect to have this that job
going into the generalization take the
rubbish and that here and I work really
closely together including on all of
these issues all of the time but you
know you and I Beth have been around for
quite a long time and we sadly we don't
we never take too seriously the sort of
you know nonsense gossip and stuff that
you know will always appear in the
papers and let's be clear in the run-up
to a general election we know there will
be all kinds of stuff appearing in the
papers that's total nonsense and that'll
be attacking us we're really going into
the general election the important thing
is that we're working together as a team
and actually setting out policies that
we have worked on together as a team
that that Kier and I have worked on that
I've been working on let's kill this
with Rachel with Bridget and so on so
let's kill this off now to be clear you
will be the shadow Home Secretary going
into the general election well look I'm
keeping working on this it's you know
it's it's for kids set out the team that
he wants and that's for him just final
question because the Sky News
investigation has revealed abuses of the
skilled worker visa scheme which allows
migrants to come here to work and bring
dependents Sky uncovered the abuse of
the scheme by people traffickers who
charge huge amounts of money to get
visas then send them fake dependents to
accompany the workers who then disappear
into the UK and arrival how worried are
you about those sorts of allegations
so I think it is really serious the way
some of the criminal gangs operate
particularly the trafficking gangs there
are also people smugger operations and
so on and we think much stronger action
is needed to go after the criminal gangs
it's partly why we've said we need a new
cross-border unit policing unit to go
after the criminal gangs but that's to
go after them in the UK and uh across
and in across Europe as well and to work
with other forces to do so I am very
worried that some of the government's
legislation is actually watering down
the action against these trafficking
gangs we think that enforcement needs to
be much stronger rather than weaker okay
if that Cooper thank you so much for
your time appreciate thank you thank you